I've been told this story ever I
remember launching winelibrary.com's new
version this was like talking about AI
back then I'm like I have a website
where I could see the orders they're
like what's a website somewhere between
99 2001 and I bought a full page ad in
the New York Times to announce it right
so this is like when print mattered like
60 000 when that was like a billion the
site didn't work it was in the store
from 7 A.M to 3 30 in the morning and
the site's not working and then we
finally get it to work at like four I
sleep for two hours I shower to go back
into the store I got into the in the
morning I remember it was like 7 30. I
clicked orders there was just orders
Park Avenue New York there was like 50
orders which was like a week's worth at
the time I remember knowing like all the
things I did all the high risk all the
work I was like that's it it's a moment